[Music]
so there's a great book by Michael
Walzer called what it means to be an
American and one of the things that he
says is that for centuries really from
the time of the Greeks political
philosophers believed that the only way
to have diversity in a society was for
it to be an empire or a dictatorship if
you wanted a democracy it had to be
homogeneous one ethnic group one racial
group and especially one religion and
then he ends that section and begins the
next section with the line until the
United States of America we are the
first mass-scale religiously diverse
democracy and I think that's a
remarkable thing and when a religiously
diverse democracy works well it's a
sight to behold you have low levels of
prejudice you have strong social
cohesion you have high levels of social
capital you have respect for different
identity communities you have the
narrative of a diverse society that
binds that society with a sense of unity
and a lot of what interfaith youth core
is about is helping America continue to
be a religiously diverse democracy that
we all ought to be proud of what strikes
me most about the founding fathers and a
set of important figures before the
founding fathers people like Roger
Williams and the people who drafted the
flushing remonstrance that's a hundred
and forty years before the founding
fathers was that this set of characters
imagined a religiously diverse democracy
and a big part of that is the separation
of church and state and a part of that
of course is to protect the state from
the church and to protect religious
communities from undue interference by
the state and it is also significantly
about the welcoming of contributions
from diverse religious communities and
so it's not like the founding fathers
were principally very devout people but
they recognized the importance of the
civic contributions of religious
communities and they certainly wanted
those communities to flourish let me
give you a couple of examples of this so
Benjamin Franklin when he lived in
Philadelphia made proactive donations to
the building funds of every religious
community that he could find in
Philadelphia different communities of
Christians a Jewish community and he
a Hall said the pulpit of this Hall will
be open to the preaching of anybody if
the Grand Mufti of Constantinople wants
to send somebody preaching about Islam
this pulpit is here for his service
right that's not just freedom of
religion that's welcoming the
contributions of diverse religious
communities George Washington when a
Jewish leader in the late 18th century
says to him what's gonna happen to to my
community to us Jews now that we have a
new nation a constitution and you are
the president and George Washington
writes in a famous document in American
history called a letter to the Hebrew
Congregation of Newport Rhode Island he
writes this government will give to
bigotry no sanction and to persecution
no assistance made the children of the
stock of Abraham sit in safety under
their own vine and fig and let there be
none to make them afraid so there is the
sense that these different religious
communities are going to help make up
the civil society that is the United
States of America I think about it as as
a potluck nation and of course that's a
play on on the term melting pot and what
I don't like about the melting pot is
obviously this notion that then you have
to kind of melt away your identity or
your distinctiveness I think what makes
America strong is not that different
communities melt away their identities
it's that they bring their identities to
the common table in the way we think
about a potluck right and a potluck is
boring if everybody brings Wonder Bread
and peanut butter a potluck is wonderful
and nutritious and festive when people
bring the various dishes that are
distinctive to their identity that's how
I think about interfaith America is a
variety of communities a variety of
orientations around religion as I said
from atheist to Zoroastrian are
contributing the best of who they are
for the Commons if different communities
don't contribute the nation doesn't
feast
[Music]